hi everyone welcome to today's homeroom
live stream uh today it's just going to
be me so we're going to do another ask
me anything so if you have any questions
for me literally about anything
start putting them on the message boards
on facebook or youtube wherever you're
watching this and we have team members
who will surface uh the questions to me
so please start thinking about those but
before we jump into the ask me anything
i'll give my standard announcements
reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization and we can
only exist or donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about going to khan
academy.org
donate and making a donation and i'll
you know our last guest where we talked
about what makes folks happy one of the
things that can actually make you a
happier person is giving to others so
when you donate to khan academy that is
going to give to many many many other
folks the the power of their potential
of their education is going to make you
a a much happier person because of it uh
also like to give a shout out to uh
several corporations who i'm guessing
are also now happier corporations
because uh over they've stepped up uh as
khan academy had to step up during covid
our cost went up our server costs went
up we've been trying to accelerate
programs and they helped us fill this
gap but we still need more help but
special thanks to bank for america
google.org att fastly and novartis
also want to remind folks about
homeroom with sal the podcast it's a
podcast version of what we're doing
right now uh edited down a little bit
for podcast purposes and it's safe to
consume while you're driving or doing
other things that you might you need
your eyes for so check that out wherever
you find your your podcast so with that
let's get into the
ask me anything and there's one that we
got a little ahead of time
from dulce castro garcia this was
actually i think on the last one from
thursday
but i figure it's a good place to start
dolce wrote mr khan until this live i
guess this live stream i didn't know who
had made the platform i love working on
so much how did you get the idea to make
the platform or what inspired you thank
you so much i'll make sure to donate
well dolce
thank you so much that you enjoy working
on khan academy
you know i a lot of folks talk about
people having a growth mindset and
people with growth mindset are
constantly challenging themselves and
pushing their boundaries and people with
growth mindset are also
disproportionately successful in life
and the fact that it sounds like you
like going to khan academy challenging
yourself keep pushing the boundaries of
your knowledge uh i think will hopefully
says a lot about you and hopefully will
be a a small part in you becoming an
incredibly empowered person and thanks
for the the willingness to to donate if
you're in a position to do so in terms
of where the inspiration for khan
academy came from you know it it goes
pretty far back
you know the khan academy immediately
started getting worked on in 2004 uh
when one of my cousins needed help i was
an analyst at a hedge fund at the time
my original background was in math and
computer science and had worked in tech
as well uh but i started tutoring her
word spread through my family free
tutoring was going on i soon found
myself tutoring 10 15 cousins around the
country i started writing software for
them
because i saw a common pattern is that
they all had gaps in their knowledge and
i wanted some ways for them to practice
and fill in those gaps and for me as
their teacher or their tutor uh to
monitor what they were doing so that
when we got on the phone we could dig a
little bit deeper and that was the first
khan academy that that exercise platform
i wrote for them and it actually still
is the core of khan academy this notion
to be able to practice and get as much
feedback as as you need and then it was
a friend in 2006 who suggested that i
make videos to supplement the exercise
portion of khan academy uh and upload
them onto youtube i thought it was a
horrible idea i told them youtube is for
cats playing piano not serious
mathematics
but i got over the idea that it wasn't
my idea and i gave it a shot
and uh you know my cousins famously told
me they liked me better on youtube than
in person
take that how you how you will i what
they were saying is that they really
appreciate having an on-demand version
an infinitely repeatable version of
their cousin that they could watch in
the middle of the night no judgment but
they still enjoyed having the phone
calls with me
but you know and then became clear
people who are not my cousins were were
using this resource and not just the
software but the videos as well
by 2009
you know i had set up khan academy as a
not-for-profit organization uh you know
to be clear what a not-for-profit is no
one owns a not-for-profit i don't own
khan academy you own as much of khan
academy as i own of khan academy none of
us own it it's really for society but i
set it up as a not-for-profit and i said
well you know the social return on
investment on this you know the social
impact could be through the roof i set
it up with the mission of free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and even though at that time
there were about 50 or 100 000 folks
using it i imagined and i was operating
out of the same closet where i am now
that maybe one day it could be millions
10 millions hundreds of millions
billions of folks and so i quit my day
job um
and and tried to find philanthropic
funding for it and that first year was a
very tough year i think any time you do
anything entrepreneurial you almost have
to have that delusional optimism assume
that people are going to step up and
realize what you think you realize but
it always takes a little bit more time
than you suspect
and so it was actually very very
stressful that that 2009 you know our
first child had just been born our
expenses went up uh my wife was still in
training to be a physician so it was it
was hard uh but as we got kind of month
nine month ten then some plans started
to come out of the woodwork
and then by that fall some major
foundations google.org the gates
foundation stepped up for us to become a
real organization so that was really the
genesis of khan academy it's been a
ongoing ride ever since um and you know
it's all because of support from
both the large foundations and
corporations and folks like yourself uh
that make this possible because you know
right now we're only really throttled
back by how much resources we can apply
to this problem that is you know affects
all of humanity but thanks for that
question luce
uh dolce i think it was your name
and then let's see youtube anuj bhagwan
you can be a billionaire but you're
doing free
but you what you what you are doing free
what is your source of energy
a new dwell um
i guess you're making an allusion to
like maybe if khan academy was
for-profit you know i would own some of
it and it could go public and maybe
worth be worth billions maybe um you
know i did the thought experiment back
when i was deciding whether to make khan
academy for-profit or non-profit and i
live in silicon valley and so there were
some venture capitalists who were
reaching out at the time and saying hey
our kids use khan academy we think
you're on to something we'll write a
quick check for you right now you can
quit your job start doing it and we
think this could be a really successful
edtech for-profit company and it was
tempting because i could immediately
work on it
maybe if it's successful i could be a
billionaire which you know i could dress
better etc
but then when i really thought about you
know what what would i do with a billion
dollars uh
you know
yes i i would probably maybe dress a
little bit i probably wouldn't even
dress any better i would uh you know i
there's i have everything i need even
back then i kind of had everything i
need i have a wonderful family uh a
smart beautiful amazing intelligent wife
i have now at the time i had one son but
now i have two sons and a daughter
they're incredibly fun and um you know
give me incredible energy and
contentment and
you know if you have those things and if
you have enough resources to pay your
mortgage go on vacations every now and
then go to a restaurant every now and
then so you're not you know struggling
financially which you know growing up i
grew up you know my mom raised us by
ourselves and she worked a lot of
minimum wage jobs so i know how hard it
is when you struggle financially
but if you're not struggling financially
if you have your base necessities you
know we have we have two hondas you know
what else could i want
and panda doesn't even pay me i'm just i
just keep buying honda's um
i'm not i'm not trying to be some type
of social media influencer i've just
always been kind of a fan of honda's
they haven't let me down
but i was like you know what would i do
with more money i would probably just
donate it all to an effort like khan
academy and so why why not even why wait
for that just do it in reverse do the
philanthropy in reverse uh just go
straight to the not for profit and then
try to find other folks who are aligned
to help fund it and you know i i do
collect a salary from it everyone at
khan academy
we're paid to do what we do uh but
obviously we're not paid in stock we're
not you know gazillionaires and and
billionaires and all that uh but i'm
very happy with that trade-off
personally in life uh you know we had
francis ford coppola on
several months ago and he he brought up
this term called you know in life a lot
of people are trying to become
millionaires or millionaires are trying
to become billionaires but he coined a
new term called sufficient air and
that's when you have enough and if you
think about if you if in your mind
you're a sufficient heir you're actually
the wealthiest of all because i know but
people who are probably worth a billion
who want to be worth 2 billion and
they're kind of waking up in the middle
of the night like how am i going to make
that next billion but if you're a
sufficient heir
then you have enough uh and and i
consider myself a sufficient air i i
i you know have hopefully reasonable
financial security uh have all what i
need um
and i get to work on a mission that is
really that i care about i get to work
with incredible people i get to do goofy
things like these amas every now and
then as part of my job uh it's
intellectually challenging so you know
what what else could i ask for so i i
have no no regrets at all
so let's see from youtube kade heplerman
says what makes you most proud of with
khan academy
um
you know when i when i meet folks either
virtually or i meet them in person and
they say that it's had an impact on
their life
uh you know i've i've gone through
airport security and you know the person
who's walking me into the the scanner
all of a sudden says hey you look
familiar
you know and they hear me talking like
you know you sound a lot like that khan
academy guy and i'm like well i i am the
khan academy guy and
then
and then they'll start talking about you
know how it helped them how it got them
through high school or how it got them
through college and it makes you know it
it feels really good uh to have that
type of feedback to hear those stories
when you're doing an otherwise not
pleasant thing like trying to check into
airport security um so that general you
know and we get letters all of the time
and that really is what gives me a lot
of energy and gives me a lot of
satisfaction and that you know i tell
this to the khan academy team all the
time you know these are the stories we
hear about but we know that there's tens
of millions of folks on the platform so
you know that
there's literally stadiums full of
people right now who are learning or
tapping into their potential because of
khan academy that might not have
otherwise been able to um and you know
for me i just think about all of that
human potential that is growing in
growing and growing i remember reading a
story about warren buffett uh this was
well before i started khan academy but
they they asked him about his investment
in gillette which makes shaving razors
and he says you know i sleep very well
at night just imagining all the hair
growing on all the men's faces around
the world and that's just going to drive
the profits of gillette well you know my
analog is i go to sleep and i just
imagine all of the people who are not
their hair is growing but their
intellect is growing their neurons are
connecting
because of khan academy and hopefully
their self-esteem is growing
because they're able to tap into their
potential and you know i don't i don't
think there's anything more exciting
than that and selfishly all of you who
are who are growing intellectually and
your self-esteem and your confidence is
growing you're going to do amazing
things many of those things are going to
benefit all of us including me so it'll
all come back you know what are y'all
going to find a cure for some disease or
you know
solve climate change or part of it or
you know write the next great novel and
hopefully if khan academy plays a little
small part of it that'd be incredible
let's see from facebook patrick breslin
how can we improve the online learning
classroom experience ideas and
improvements in 2020 and beyond
um
well there's some high level things that
actually don't need technology
i think when you're doing i think the
interactive live video conference is
crucial especially if you're doing
distance learning now to be clear i
don't think distance learning is optimal
100 distance learning is not optimal for
most people including for myself you
need to be in a classroom interact with
people see body language that stuff is
super powerful but there's i mean
obviously during covid we have to do
distance learning and then beyond kovid
there could be spaces for it where it
gives you access to courses that might
not be available in your school or
connected to students who you might not
otherwise be able to connect with but
whenever you're doing anything distance
especially video conference you got to
make it as interactive as possible i
mean if i just lecture to you all right
now without looking at your questions
it might as well be a video
and ideally if we're all really live on
a video conference uh you know i should
be asking y'all questions and seeing
your responses putting you into breakout
sessions being creative on the use of
time instead of 60 minutes with 30 kids
why not
six
six 10 minute sessions with five kids
each so you can get a little bit more
personalization break it up every now
and then just fun activities close your
eyes and you know draw an elephant and
then share it with everyone maybe in a
breakout session those are the types of
things that when we see are done well
make it really engaging and frankly
everything i just said are also good
practices in a physical classroom make
it as interactive as possible human to
human
um
from youtube hari aburu says
how did you manage to upload millions of
videos helping millions of people well
you know harry to be clear khan academy
is much more than just me
the and i haven't uploaded millions of
videos personally i have made thousands
of videos i think it's probably about
six or seven thousand at this point and
you know it seems like a lot but when
you look at how many days in the year
there are times i've been making videos
for about 14 years now um yeah you can
you can get several thousand you know if
you if you think about uh
yeah you know if you say roughly over 10
years 7 000 videos i mean i've been
doing it for a little bit more than 10
years
you're looking at about 700 videos a
year if you think i've been doing it for
about 12 13 14 years it's a little bit
lower maybe 500 600 videos a year and so
that's averaging about you know there's
about 250 workdays so i'm averaging
about two to five videos per workday and
i still make videos i made one this
morning i still haven't uploaded yet
it's it's it's coming it's simpsons
diversity index in biology of how do you
quantify diversity in a population
let's see so hari asks another question
what do you think is the hardest topic
in mathematics
um
you know what i found is any topic in
mathematics it can sometimes seem hard
at first because it's kind of stretching
your thinking it's making you visualize
things in a different way or it might
even be things that you find trouble
visualizing like you know i remember the
first time you know in linear algebra
you do the you you know you start
generalizing this notion of of
two-dimensional three-dimensional and
then you go to n space that you can have
an arbitrary number of dimensions
um and then you can essentially do
linear algebra within those arbitrary
number of dimensions and it and
mathematically you can come up with some
really interesting conclusions about
things or insights about things and at
first i remember thinking
how do i think beyond three dimensions i
mean maybe we can think in four
dimensions if you include time
but you know the more you get familiar
with it your brain it is true the human
brain cannot really
visualize through four dimensions or
definitely not five dimensions
but you can start to think about how it
works and actually the math
can help you think about what happens
what would it be like to experience if
if we had four spatial dimensions or
five spatial dimensions or or things
like that so you know
i think and there's other topics in
mathematics that can be very abstract uh
you know it might seem very esoteric but
what i found is the more in any subject
not just math that you really apply
yourself to it you allow your
subconscious to ponder a little bit uh
give yourself some time and space at
some point those connections are gonna
are gonna happen and i'm actually
convinced
anything that is understandable by any
other human being is actually
understandable by any other human being
just given enough time you know if you
go back a thousand years things like
algebra were considered like super
advanced you know like only the the
elite of the elite mathematicians um
would you know i'll call is me famously
is the one who really invented algebra
and algebra is you know it's algebra it
comes from arabic you know and this was
kind of in the in the kind of the golden
age of kind of islamic mathematics you
know i think it coincides with the
famous library in baghdad so back then
for much of the world this was like
super advanced stuff i think this was in
the 11th or 12th century uh but you fast
forward today we expect you know
pretty much you know you start learning
algebra in sixth grade you know 11 or 12
years old and you really are supposed to
master algebra at least the core of it
by the time you're in ninth or tenth
grade um so i think you know even things
like
tensor analysis or topology or
you know i could come up with some of
these abstract things i think
over time we're gonna they're gonna
become more and more common for more and
more people to to really understand
these things
so from youtube sudhir yadav says how
could i balance my life between monthly
exams and what i really want to do in
life
good question and i would say you know
the key is balance no matter what stage
of life you're at whether you're a
student and you have to take your exams
and study for them or whether you're
working and you have some passions you
want to work on i i think if you really
determine yourself you say look i am
going to set aside x hours a day maybe
it's only an hour a day two hours or
maybe it's only three hours on the
weekend to do this thing i care about
you should be able to do it you you
there's a lot of stuff we do when we're
procrastinating not efficient use of
time that when we really think about it
and you know reflect on it we're like it
really doesn't make us feel good um let
me focus that energy on the stuff that i
really want to work on and you know i i
say this because khan academy wouldn't
exist y'all heard the story of how it
started if i said i'm a hedge fund
analyst that's all i'm going to do my
cousin needs help but i'm going to
ignore her khan academy exists because i
had a you know i said i'm going gonna
this is important to me i'm interested
in tutoring i want to help my cousin uh
and i'm i want to write software i want
to help them and i'm curious about the
broader problem of education
let me carve out some time for this and
you know when you do that you think it
might affect your your day job but in a
lot of ways it doesn't and it actually
makes you better at your day job because
then when you go to your day job you're
more energized recharged and you're used
to thinking in in kind of different ways
so even now you know there's a million
things i want to get done with khan
academy and when friday afternoon or
evening comes around i'm like maybe i
should just work through the weekend and
crank that stuff out but i remind myself
that if i do that i'm just going to
deplete myself and actually probably
make be less effective in my role at
khan academy and that you know i should
invest that time be present for my own
needs for my wife's needs for my
children's needs um
so that one it's for for them but also
for myself you know i think no one on
their deathbed wishes that they had
worked for their job a little bit harder
everyone on their deathbed i think or a
lot of folks when on their deathbed when
you're in your you know hopefully a long
time from now they say oh i wish i spent
more time with my family i wish i
invested more in my passions i wish i
you know when my kids were young i i
really appreciated them you know i i
look at videos now of you know my kids
are eleven nine and six uh and i look at
videos from even four or five years ago
when they were when they were younger
and i was like man they were these
little chunky monkeys how come i didn't
squeeze them all day and then i remember
how tiring it was as well so i was
probably just tired um but i remind
myself that in five years when i see
videos of my own kids today i'm like oh
look how cute and adorable they were and
they were so fun and curious how how
come you you ignored them when you were
trying to write that you know memo to a
whatever whatever
um and so i just remind myself all the
time it's all about balance and making
and you know and really prioritizing uh
your your your inner self your family
and the your friendships uh so that they
don't get lost and it's not gonna hurt
you know your other things you have to
do whether it's academics or or a job
so let's see
uh youtube susana garcia dominguez you
know i don't want to have favorite
question askers but susanna has
consistently asked some very good
questions so
not to make any uh make all of y'all
feel bad i haven't seen the question
she's going to ask to see hello sal
thank you for having homeroom today i
was wondering about mit
do they have a big endowment what
scholarships are best to apply for what
is the best way to fund mit i'm assuming
fund fund as a student if you want to go
because mit is a reasonably wealthy
university they have a i don't know what
their endowment is today but it's in the
billions of dollars um
so uh but you know they do great things
so if anyone's thinking about funding
mit you know they do some incredible
research uh so i'm a big fan that's
that's where i went to went to college
i'm guessing that's why suzanne is
asking me about that but
what scholarships are the best to apply
for what is the best way to fund i'm
assuming going to mit so you know
when i was in high school
my mom didn't make a lot of money i
think she was making i think five
dollars an hour which even in you know
the 1990s was not a lot of money it was
minimum wage uh and my older sister
actually applied to brown university
which is another very good university
ivy league university i remember when
she was applying i was like even if you
get in how are we gonna we can't afford
going there at the time i think brown's
tuition was twenty thousand dollars a
year which was more than my mother made
in a year uh and then room and board
would have been another ten thousand
dollars a year so back then it would
have been about thirty thousand dollars
a year now
these places are fifty sixty thousand
dollars a year in some cases um
and then my sister told me you know sal
there's this thing called financial aid
uh and if you get into some of these
universities not all universities have
them but universities like brown
universities like mit that have
reasonable size endowments they first of
all try to be need blind or i think they
are need blind when they look at an
applicant so they're not looking at you
whether you're going to be able to pay
or not and then if you get admitted they
try to make it so that you can pay and
actually and so when i was you know my
sister was able to
you know get she had a good bit of loans
uh but then she also uh had some a lot
of grants from school and then she um
was able to go and so that would made me
realize oh wait maybe i could also think
about it was always my dream when i was
young to to go to mit a little bit
arbitrary i remember when i was seven
years old my uncle who was in his 20s at
the time at the university of new
orleans he was he was a college student
and he was doing his calculus homework
and i was like what is this he's like
this is calculus i'm like what is
calculus and he's like well it's a
little complicated like explain it to me
and and then he explains and he's like i
was like why do you need to learn
calculus he's like well i want to become
an engineer and then i'll be able to do
x y and z you know make things and i
said then i want to become an engineer
and then he said then you should go to
mit and he doesn't remember saying that
but i remember saying okay i will go to
mit i didn't know what it stood for i
didn't know where it was but something
clicked in my brain at seven years old
and when i saw that my sister kind of
pioneered that like oh there's this
thing called financial aid that gave me
the confidence to apply
um and even that i realized at the time
was a little delusional
no one in my high school had ever
gone to mit and they only you know were
accepting at the time five or six people
from the state of louisiana and i did
not go to one of those fancy schools um
but you know somehow i got in and they
gave me a i thought a very generous
financial aid package so i did have debt
you know i had like thirty thousand
dollars of debt when i graduated and my
and you know but for the most part all
the contribution came from me and my
work study and my mom didn't have to
contribute much um and my understanding
now a lot of these schools if your
family makes i believe it's below 75 000
a year it's essentially
free uh and i think in some cases if
your family makes below 125 000 or 150
000 a year it's it's still heavily
heavily subsidized so any of you all
thinking about going it's not just mit
or brown there's probably there's a lot
of universities look into it that give
need blind that need blind admissions
and give very generous financial aid so
don't let your family's finances
narrow the aperture of where you might
where you might want to go to college
let's see from facebook
maya campbell if you weren't leading
khan academy what do you think you'd be
doing instead
um
so there's a bunch of projects that i
think in the education space generally
i've always been interested in the stuff
we're doing at khan academy
some of y'all know i've been working on
this project at schoolhouse.world
very complementary to khan academy
around peer-to-peer tutoring although i
view that as all part of the same
broader mission uh you know ways for
students to know what they what they
know so that they can approve it uh you
know college you know
for things like college admissions uh
near chicago just announced a couple
weeks ago that they were going to use
these schoolhouse.world certifications
uh for for admission cycle this year so
i
you know i think i i'd be drawn i even
was working at the hedge fund i was
saying i'll start a school one day if
i'm able to make enough money in the
hedge fund because i always thought it
would be fun to be a dumbledore type
figure so i think i would be doing
something in education
eventually if you're saying if i wasn't
working in education at all
uh what would i be doing you know maybe
i would have studied in the hedge fund
world uh to some degree uh and you know
tried to become but but even then i i
would have viewed that as a means to an
end uh and you know i think my my my
biggest interests are
i mean my general interest is in human
potential and so that's why i'm so
interested in education and then you
know a more recent passion that i've
really been developing y'all have heard
me talk about it on this live stream is
just kind of going on an inward journey
like understanding who we are as
sentient beings and so that's why i've
been meditating a lot
i've been actually investing
time to get to know my friends better we
we meet on sundays and we have these and
now we do it on zoom where we have these
conversations about you know what does
it mean to be a good person and how
what's perception versus reality and
things like that so maybe i would have i
would have become some type of
you know
uh
you know community builder type type
type type person uh who knows who knows
i also like you know on the side i am i
i think i i'm always drawn to kind of
real estate maybe i would have been some
type of like you know home fixer-upper
there's something very tangible about
that
like that's just a random that that's
just a random other interest uh that i
that i i might have had a lot of my
friends know uh anyone who i know who
who wants to buy a house they turn to me
right now i'm like their shadow real
estate broker um because it's just kind
of a
fun thing that i like to do when i'm
procrastinating uh
um so
fa fatah bobber is asking from youtube
how do i learn how to teach
um
well the best way to learn anything is
to keep doing it getting feedback and
really processing that feedback my
general
you know if i were to give i haven't
thought a lot about this but you know
step one learn the material really
really well yourself not only so that
it's really intuitive for you but you're
excited about it because if you don't
have excitement if it's not intuitive to
you it's going to be very hard to convey
the excitement and the intuition to
someone else so that's step one the
second thing is you know try to build
the empathy of really putting yourself
in the mind of the person you're trying
to explain to
don't try to force the knowledge into
them cater to their needs be as
empathetic as possible you know be as
patient as possible try to meet them
where they are and just be
conversational you know don't talk down
don't talk above them just say look
we're just two souls trying to
understand this you know i just happen
to know it already and let's see how i
can help you i think if you have that
kind of relaxed
but still passionate and very intuitive
angle on something people are going to
really enjoy
um you know learning with you and going
on a learning adventure that's that's my
my my gut sense
time's going by fast
let me do a couple more questions um
which skill do you think is the most
useful for the future this is from kuram
amir mazar from facebook
um
the
you know the meta skill is the ability
to learn things you know the one thing
we know about the next century is that
the rate of change is only going to
accelerate you know there's these famous
stats i don't know how they come up with
it that the majority of the jobs that
all of y'all are going to have um you
know 10 20 30 years from now don't exist
yet today so we don't even know what
those jobs are and so the real skill you
learn is how do you how do you pull
knowledge and the beauty is right now on
the internet through khan academy and
other things the knowledge is all there
there's million ways to learn the skills
and so you just have to get good at
doing it so when you're on khan academy
yes you can learn to factor a polynomial
and you can learn about photosynthesis
and you can learn about the american
revolution but and that's all important
content to learn and skills to learn but
that meta skill of learning to go
learning at your own time and space and
using tools at your disposal to do so uh
that's really uh an incredible skill and
you know and based on the last question
i think the ability to teach others
is an incredibly valuable skill
not just for becoming a teacher if you
think about what a good manager does in
a corporation they're good supporters
and teachers and mentors of other people
that's what
you know you need to communicate when
you teach you need to empathize when you
teach you need to inspire when you teach
and if you think about those three
things are completely synonymous with
leadership or any type of
entrepreneurship as well so i would say
the ability to teach and the ability to
learn new things
let's see
one more
question or maybe i'll do two real fast
youtube mmbl they say khan academy's
great area for set prep i really need to
raise my score 200 points or more what
do you advise me to do
you know if you go on khan academy use
the official sat practice which we have
in partnership with the college board
and you put in i don't know when you
plan on taking the sat i'm guessing you
might be a sophomore junior it's a
little late now if you're applying for
college right now but maybe maybe you
are no don't stress um
but you know i would put in 20 30
minutes a day you know maybe four or
five days a week and you know we
actually have done research there's
if you follow the recommendations on the
official sat practice the stuff that the
software is saying you need to work on
you really focus on leveling up your
skills so you know to kind of higher and
higher levels on it and you you once and
every now and then you take full length
practice tests and as realistic format
as possible we see in the data that
that's really going to drive a lot of
growth and especially if you have some
time before your sct and you just make a
habit 20 30 minutes a day follow the
recommendations work on what you need to
work on take those full length practice
tests i think in a few months you're
going to see
pretty noticeable gains and if you have
even more than a few months i actually
felt feel pretty confident you'll be
able to you know reach reach reach your
goals maybe it'll happen sooner
and then or we're all over time
um
this one youtube aten mera says how do
you have so much depth of knowledge and
almost in most domains it seems to be
quite extraordinary for a single person
to do well
i appreciate that you that that that you
feel
that i have this you know this depth and
you know look that is one of the things
that
why i feel lucky to have this job that i
get to exercise that depth and many
domains and then communicate it to other
folks but you know
i think we're all just curious beings in
this thing we call life in this universe
that we're trying to understand and
almost all knowledge is just trying to
make sense of who we are and what the
universe is all about and what i found
is if you can draw connections in one
domain it translates into other domains
more than you might suspect i think in a
traditional school system we silo the
subject so much that you don't realize
that you know ways that of learning and
ways of connection in your brain are not
as siloed as you think it's not like
your brain has like a math section and
then separately a physics section and
then separately
an
art section you know these neurons are
all jumbled together uh and so for me
it's very fun to
ponder things to learn things to be able
to communicate things
and i think if you just have the mindset
for yourself like i'm just going to keep
learning and i'm just a curious person
and i too want to learn everything i
think when you're sitting you know in
your mid-40s on a live stream and your
beard is growing a little bit uh you
know people will be sending you
questions like you just sent me
uh so thanks everyone for for this is
always super fun these these ask me any
things a couple of announcements uh
tomorrow
uh october 22nd i don't know what day is
today is today the no that's day after
tomorrow we're going to have a
motivation webinar from kristen deservo
our chief learning officer and i highly
recommend this kristen is great she is
an expert on all things learning and she
is also very engaging herself so encara
encourage
parents
to check out this webinar on how to
motivate middle and high school kids
during distance learning
also want to remind folks that tomorrow
we're going to have pedro nogueira the
dean of the university of southern
california's roster school of education
so start thinking of questions for dean
nogueira that's going to be a great
conversation so everyone thanks for
joining these ask many things are always
fun and i will see you tomorrow
onward
you